Okay, so the correct answers are not because posts can't return HTML.
We've seen that posts can return HTML.
They can return our error page, for example.
Reloading our success page doesn't resubmit the form.
That's a nice benefit to remove the form parameters from URL.
Technically, if you had a get request that submitted your form,
and then you redirected when a form was valid,
yes you can remove the form parameters from the URL.
However, if you're sending data to the server with the get request
you have not been paying attention to this lesson.
So I'm not going to count this as correct.
Finally, so we can have distinct pages for forms and success pages.
This is also true.
What I've been getting at is this nice behavior you can have
where you have your forms, and you submit that form over and over, you post to it,
and you keep getting that form over and over until it's valid.
Once it's valid we bounce the user, we redirect the user to another page,
whether it's a permalink to the blog post they just entered
or a thank you for being so good at entering dates page,
to a thanks for registering on our website page.
There's lots of things you want to do there, but having separate pages for those is nice.
It's a nice way to structure app.
So let's go ahead and make this change to the app we've been working on.